all right
hello everyone i am adrian teca i'm
based in las vegas
and if i'm unusually chipper it's
because this is
the first time a conference like this
has been in favor of my time zone so i'm
very happy
that it's the normal waking hours for me
here it's around
3 pm for me today i'd like to talk to
you
about nosql databases specifically
i'm hoping to possibly re-shift your
mindset
and maybe even get you to say yes to
nosql databases
so let's get to it
so as relational developers or
developers who are used to working with
relational databases
relational databases are probably your
bread and butter
they were mine they were the first data
model and type of database that i worked
with when i started out as
a software developer and that's kind of
just what we
use right we didn't really have a need
for anything else or we probably didn't
learn anything else and so along with
that
you know all the other parts of it kind
of became second nature
sql is your jam joins where necessary
data is relational that's why they're
called relational databases
and for the most part they they work
kind of but they they worked
so when this new kid around the black
came in
called nosql they're probably just like
me like what is it
why would i need this what exactly is
nosql
and to that i say you're completely
justified
i mean it's been used in so many
different ways it's been interchanged in
different ways we call it nosql
non-sql or non-sql however you like to
say it
non-relational sql not only sql
so with all of these different
definitions and
variations and mutations of what we
assume
nosql is it's not really uh hard to see
why a lot of people are not
distinct and clear about what is a
definitive nosql databases
and but this is not uh a problem
because there are different permutations
of it so
keeping this in mind i like to think of
it
this way at least in um
in contrast in contrast to what
relational developers think of
and so nosql is basically a different
way of
storing and modeling data than the
regular
form that we are used to now keep in
mind
these databases the notion of nosql
databases
they've actually already existed for
quite some time in fact they
already were around in the 1960s but it
did not gain popularity and
surge into tech buzzword lan until about
the late 2000s when
costs of storage have dramatically
increased
and that makes more sense because as
we'll see in a bit nosql databases have
some characteristics that make it
more pragmatic for storage to cost way
less than what it did before
so if not tabular data then how do we
model it what do we do
we're used to our nice structured tables
and
joins and foreign keys how else would we
model this kind of data
well there are four different ways four
common ways that you would find
that are related to no sql and nosql
data models
in particular so the first is the
document store
this is where you can store data in
hierarchical ways
and they're stored within json based
documents
i think i work for one that you may know
it's called mongodb
but there are others a second
form of a data model for nosql
is the key value store so this one at
least when i first started learning
about all the different models
was a little bit more self-explanatory
the literal keys
and values and you would use these keys
to quickly
query any of the data that you may need
and it's so fast
because you would probably hash those
keys to be able to get it
quickly so think your redises your rocks
db your apache ignites
next there's the wide column store you
they might be interchanged with columnar
columnar stores i always
say that incorrectly i always get
self-conscious when i say it because i
think i'm saying it wrong i'm gonna say
wide column store
and this is where related data is stored
as a set
of nested key value pairs within a
single column
so for me when i first read that and
even saw some of the diagrams that
didn't really make sense to me but what
did make sense to me is if you imagine
let's say you had a customer column and
within that column you actually had
two things like name or address some
sort of related data that you would want
to query
together now you might have another
column with completely different data
but is related to that person or that
row id
and let's say you're the product column
that could include the item and the
price
so in the wide column strategy you would
then
be able to query either via a user id or
something which would equate to the row
of that table but be able to quickly get
the actual
group of data that you need in this wide
column store
so these are your ciladbs and your
cassandras
and finally there are the graph store
models
so this is where we store data in nodes
and edges
so nodes store the entities the nouns
the people the places
the things uh that of the data that
we're capturing
and the edges store the relationships or
i like to call them the verbs of what is
related among these things these
entities so these are your neo4js and
your janus graph
so keeping in mind that these are a
different way of modeling data
and that they have a different approach
to storing data
naturally the next question that usually
comes to mind when we start discussing
this
is all right so are nosql database is
better than relational databases
well technically i'm paid to say yes
but the real answer of course is it
depends the lovely answer
that is right almost all of the time it
depends
and so in order to truly understand why
the differences matter and how we can
use some of the things we uh or use the
differences in our
decision making we need to get some
dependencies
into this presentation in fact
we need to import some dependencies into
this
presentation about some of the
fundamentals and
i know if you've heard this before it
might just be a quick refresher but i
promise you that
laying these fundamentals down and
understanding them will help in
the later part of this presentation and
hopefully in the later course
when you are making a decision on
whether or not to choose a nosql
database for your system
so those three dependencies are going to
be the cap theorem
acid and base and before anyone says
anything
before you start typing in the chat in
slack and saying oh this has been
outdated this has been debated yes i
have read those articles i've read
martin klepman's response to
uh to cap theorem i understand
but the point i want to make here is to
the fundamentals still stand and they
still
uh give us a very good framework of at
least asking us
or forcing us to ask the questions with
ourselves
and with our team on whether or not we
need some of these properties and things
when we are deciding on a technology to
choose
so keeping that in mind we'll go through
them
so cap theorem also known as brewer's
theorem
based on the computer scientist eric
brewer who has
projected this out into the world and so
he states
in a distributed system it is impossible
to have
more than two of the following three
properties
that's consistency availability and
partition tolerance
cap right because we just need more
acronyms and tech so quickly what are
those
because even these are contested in what
they actually mean
and at least for the context of this
presentation i'd like to tell you what
i see them as they're what
i feel they should be consistency
states that a read from any node is
guaranteed
to return the most recent estate
so what does that exactly mean let's say
i have a cluster
and i have four nodes and in these four
nodes these are four computers whatever
i'll call them nodes just to be more
generic
uh we can read and write to this cluster
and right now the current state of my
cluster is uh it has
hey there in all four of the nodes
that's the state that's the value of
all four nodes now let's say i want to
update the value to comusta instead of
hey there because i figured if for those
who already know cap theorem hey maybe
you'll learn
something new too so comista is hey
there or hello
in tagalog and when we send this call
when we send this operation to
my cluster what will happen is as
expected
it will probably update the first node
that it reaches that accepts the call
but in an inconsistent system what could
happen
is that before replication is finished
we might actually acknowledge to the
client that hey i'm done
i've written and this is inconsistent
because what if right after that we
decided we wanted to
read something and this is done before
the replication has finished
and let's say that this read call was
sent to node
3. well you can see the problem we're
going to get the value hey there instead
of
kumusta so this is where we say it's an
inconsistent system
because it has it we're receiving steel
data we're not getting the guarantee of
the kamusta on all of the nodes that we
are
expecting contrast that to a
consistent system what would probably
happen is we wouldn't acknowledge to the
client that we were done
until it has been fully uh
confirmed that everything has been
replicated to the majority of the nodes
to all of the nodes depending on
you know some really granular things
like write safety and write preferences
and mongodb
and all the other options but in a
consistent system we would be
guaranteed that no matter which call is
made
and no matter which node accepts it we
are going to get the same
data so that's consistency
a read from any node is guaranteed to
return the most recent state
next is availability so
availability in the cap theorem states
that every request
received by a non-failing node will
return a response
meaning no errors or timeouts either
so let's go back to our cluster same
four nodes same values all hey there
now in an available system
uh if we made a call we would be able to
still
receive a response despite having say
two nodes
go offline just like it did in my
cluster an available system would be
able to
write komusta and it it will
uh reconcile the um replication of this
in the back end but to the client to the
front end it's it's always available
so that's where we get the problem of it
could still be sending us stale data
because it's always available
and you'll see that with if we try to
say
read this now and that read call went to
let's say the third node
we'd still get hey there so there's that
possibility of
steel data in this particular system
but being available just means that even
if there are nodes down in the cluster
we are able to still have a functioning
system
it doesn't break because two nodes are
down
so availability every request received
by a non-failing node is going to get a
response
and lastly partition tolerance so
despite
network partitions aka when connections
are
severed between nodes they can't
communicate to each other
again this the system should still
function
so back to our cluster we have four
nodes hey there is all there
that's everything's fine and dandy right
now let's say that some communication
breaks between
node one and node four there's no way
for them to talk to each other
and uh you know if this needed to write
or
replicate something it's not able to do
so because the communication has been
severed
well a partition tolerant system
says that even if this state exists
right now even if node 1 and node 4
can't talk to each other we're still
going to get a response the
the system is still going to be
functional for
the user
so partition tolerance despite network
disconnectivity or severed connections
between nodes
systems should still function
so cap's theorem says that we should
only
choose between these two or we can only
have two
out of the three we can only have two
out of three of consistency
availability and partition tolerance
and again we can argue that that is kind
of being challenged right now
with spanner but again we'll save that
for later
so this means that this area right here
in the middle that we can't possibly
have all three at least
with a fundamental understanding that
most of us have
known for a while so
with this in mind this means that there
are several combinations left for us to
deliberate on when we choose
on how to architect our system but
do we really because of the nature of
distributed systems
we really only have to choose between
two options or we are only left with
one or the other choice that we need to
deliberate on because
one has kind of already been chosen for
us
so one of the logical fallacies
of distributed computing is that the
network is reliable
you'll even see here it's listed as on
the official wikipedia
of fallacies of distributed computing
it's number one on dare that that
the number one fallacy is the network is
reliable
networks are not reliable they go down
they go down many times it's unexpected
i know many of you have probably
encountered some sort of issue with a
video call
networks are unreliable
and so because we understand that
network failures
will occur and they will at some point
happen to our system
it's it's a given we must tolerate
partitions
in a distributed system so this is why i
say
partition tolerance is an automatic
choice it's
not left to us if we're going to work
with distributed systems
it is chosen by default for us
so now we're left with two options right
do we choose
partition tolerant consistent systems or
do we choose partition tolerant
available systems in other words which
one are we willing to
sacrifice consistency or availability
in partition tolerant consistent systems
obviously we're sacrificing availability
but here if we choose a system like this
or build
a system like this when consistency
cannot be ensured we will probably get
errors or timeouts
and in this kind of system that should
be acceptable
because we care more about the data
integrity
rather than the availability of our
system
so if consistency is crucial to the user
experience
then these are some factors that you
would consider and maybe leaning towards
a
partition tolerant consistent system so
you have to decide are errors okay to
show
the client or are they not is
consistency
literally the thing that matters most in
this application
or is it not and that's why the example
of financial transactions or financial
applications kind of uses this because
we all want to make sure our money is in
our bank accounts and it's the right
amount now if we go the other direction
we save them consistency is not really
too important
availability is way more important in
our application
in our system now we may not get errors
or timeouts
but the problem here now is that the
data you receive could be
outdated so even though it's always
always on always available to
the user what's more important in these
systems is that
data accumulation the amount of
processing and rights that you're able
to do
on this system is more important than
data integrity
so in these cases it's it's where
eventual consistency is acceptable
it's where everything does not have to
be the same mutual state
correct at the same time it's if this is
at some later point it gets to
the right state that's okay and so
these are the some of the things that
you have to consider when you are
deciding between
these kinds of trade-offs and one last
thing to note about this
is that so when we we learned about this
or maybe if you're hearing about this
for the first time
it might seem like these are these very
binary design decisions right you have
to sacrifice full availability you have
to sacrifice
full consistency and that's absolutely
not the case in fact eric brewer himself
came back you know some years later it
was like it's not really
that that rigid what's happening more
and more
nowadays is it's more like a balancing
act what are the trade-offs
that you are willing to make what are
the trade-offs that your system
can make and are acceptable that's what
we are struck by are trying to find now
but the fundamentals of this still stand
where it
allows us to ask those questions to get
to those answers
to see what is worth uh sacrificing and
what what's
what percentage or level of consistency
and availability we want to balance
so the funniest thing about this is that
while i was you know
finishing up my slides on on this and
talking about consistency and
availability and making sure all my
animations are
sparkly smooth at around 8 35 p.m last
night
um i used slides.com to create my slides
i used to use reveal js which is the
open source project that this is based
on but it got way too tedious
so i gave in and got slides.com and i
got this
and this is the last thing i wanted to
see at this point i was telling myself
you know what slides.com i'd actually
i'd rather you be available right now
than consistent but alas we're still
here i was still able to make my changes
and i only lost maybe a couple objects
so
it's a it's a win for me
great so now we've laid the foundation
for cap ethereum we understand
the trade-offs that we have to make
between consistency and availability
in a system where we are
now assuming that partition tolerance is
default it's by nature it's a
distributed system that is chosen for us
it has to be
that way the next thing that we need to
understand is the acid properties
versus base properties so you've seen
these acronyms before
maybe or if you've ever done any kind of
research on databases you'll
you'll see this somewhere and what i
want to make very clear
is that these are not one-to-one
direct comparisons of the properties of
each other
they are more like a set of guidelines
that you
again have to decide if it is right for
your system or not
so the consistency model in acid
very quickly a atomic all
operations in a transaction succeed
otherwise roll back the entire operation
either it all happens or it doesn't at
all
and then for c consistent meaning upon
the completed transaction
the database is structurally sound
meaning that the data should be in a
consistent state both before
and after a transaction i is isolated
that means if you have concurrently
running transactions they shouldn't
affect each other they shouldn't contend
with one another and the d stands for
durable
so upon a completed transaction despite
any failures
the results that happen should be
permanent
so meaning if there are any hardware or
software failures
any changes that have been committed to
the database
should still remain so as you can
kind of sense or if you've worked with
this or you know you needed this in your
systems
you'll know that these are are very
rigid they're almost like a pessimistic
model
a pessimistic consistency model that you
need to guarantee and these are
very much directly related to the
transactions themselves in databases
so that's one thing to keep in mind
because these acid
guarantees kind of imply not always but
imply that
right safety is more important for you
now if we compare the base properties
base ba basic availability means the
database appears to work
mostly it's mostly available it's mostly
there the s
stands for soft state which means that
the database state
you need to be aware that it could
change over time
and due to eventual consistency and also
if there are no inputs that are
happening at the moment
and e itself is eventual consistency
so the database will be consistent at
some later
point so knowing all of this you can
already see
that these are much looser properties
they're not as
rigid as acid and in fact a lot of
um research has shown that nosql
databases
kind of naturally fall more into the
base properties
because they um have those more lacks
uh guidelines than acid but
these are again things that you need to
understand and be aware of
because if you can get your team and
yourself
to acknowledge and answer these
questions of what your system actually
needs
you'll actually be better off in the
long run when we finally get to the
point of
choosing a nosql technology
if you ever get to a point and if it
makes sense for you
so all make sense very very soon
so we have spoken about cap theorem
we've spoken about acid
we've spoken about base so now
we can finally get into the what i call
the three-step guide
of ditching relational databases so
number one now that we have the
fundamentals covered
the first thing that we need to discuss
is
is nosql actually the way to go in the
very
end is this even a you know this is the
first question you should
ask and start with because this will
not only cut you off short uh this will
also lead the way into whether or not
nosql databases should be the way to go
and how do you do that well there are
more things that you have to consider
but for this first step what you really
need to take a look at
is your data specifically four
characteristics of your data
and what how they describe your data so
when you're determining whether or not
nosql is the way to go
you want to look at your data volume
your data velocity
your data variety and your data valence
and as a general rule very quick tldr
if you have large data volume if you
have
high data velocity if you have
volatility or high volatility varied
types
of varieties of data and if you have a
high date of valence
then generally nosql is probably the way
to go for
you so that's like general rule
although there could definitely be some
exceptions but for the most part if you
follow along that spectrum nosql is
probably a
good bet so what do these mean exactly
there's all these
words and i like to structure things and
and use alliteration here with all the
same letters but what does this actually
mean
so to start data volume meaning the size
of your stored data
how large is your stored data and if you
look at
the data sets that we have now large
data sets are becoming
even larger they are so large in fact
that
they are almost becoming too unwieldy
when we store them
in a traditional relational database
model
so what that means is whenever we have
to query something
whenever we have to query against a
really large volume of data
if it's in a relational model and if it
has been modeled
the way we are used to which means
there's going to be lots of tables
there's going to be a high number of
joins
then it's going to be very very very
slow
so it's not a fault of relational
databases
themselves but rather the data model
so in this particular case i say if your
volume is
large no sql is probably a better
option than a relational data model
because they are much
better at handling today's larger data
sets they've been built
to improve upon that fact
next is data velocity and what i mean by
this
is the rate at which your data changes
over time
so there's two parts to this and the
first one
is if um you have high right lows
meaning
if the rate at which your actual data
points change meaning how many edits you
have and how much
how many times you have to write to the
database if that is high
and if the actual data structure your
data model
your schemas change constantly
over time if both of those are high then
again it's another
consideration uh leaning towards nosql
being the better
option for you think about it
so if you pair the first characteristic
which is having a large volume of data
you pair that high volume with really
constant
high right loads you're basically
pushing whatever database that you're
using
to deal with this amount of surging
uh database activity you're going to be
peaking all the time
and then when you talk about the data
structure you have
the changes that occur over time
and this can happen for many reasons
businesses move fast
organizations acquire data data
acquisition is experimental
you realize that the model you had was
not correct or maybe you have new things
that you need to capture
and again if you've worked with this in
a relational model
you know the pain of migrating a data
model especially if it's only just
adding
one extra um field and into the table
with all of these uh you have to
consider
that if you have these characteristics
if you have
large volumes of data that you're
dealing with if your velocity is high
meaning you know you have a lot of
rights and you know that your data model
is changing
constantly you almost require a database
that
is optimized for the high right loads
and for the flexible data models
those are two things that a relational
database is not
usually prepared to handle and even more
so if they're not properly tuned
so it's not saying they're absolutely
not possible
it's just saying no sql databases have
been built with this in mind
and so for that if you do have high
velocity
then nosql is probably a better way to
go
thirdly data variety if you have high
data variety
meaning then the types of data that you
are storing is super varied it's
it's all over the place it's not
homogeneous at all
then again no sql is probably the way to
go
data is so diverse there's dense data
and sparse data there's data that's
connected and disconnected
data that is structured semi-structured
irregularly structured i mean with the
amount of data that we are capturing now
from all kinds of different devices from
all kinds of different sources
there are just so many different ways
that the data can come
in and for that we
we have four data models that i spoke
about earlier
which again have adopted their own
strategy to deal
with the how to handle this variety of
data
that we see and i know that there
are databases that can accommodate say
json
for example but they're kind of always
built as an afterthought
so meaning yes you can store json in
there in a relational database
but you're not going to get the native
capabilities that you would in nosql
databases
so for example in mongodb you can do
embedded searches within
embedded documents or you can have
automatic indexes on
nested fields and that would be
something that's very difficult to do
and certainly not native
in some sort of add-on
or a database that does offer the
storage of json
and so for that if your data is all over
the place
it's again one thing to consider that
nosql is probably the way to go
and finally data valence so
that's here i have it as connections
that exist
within your data it's the ratio of
connections that exist within your data
compared to the total number of possible
connections
so when i first researched this and was
learning about this i'm like that
doesn't make any sense to me
so i i hopefully these things will help
so fun fact
latin root of valence is the same as
value or valere which means to be strong
to be powerful
influential or healthy now when i think
about this in different spaces
i think it starts to make more sense in
chemistry
valence is the combining power of an
element in psychology valence means the
intrinsic attractiveness of an object
and in linguistics it's the number of
elements that
a word combines so keeping
those kind of parallel definitions of it
in the context of data valence is the
tendency
of the individual data to connect
as well as the overall connectedness of
the data set
itself and if that still doesn't make
sense because
i know it took me a while the explain
like like m5 version is the higher
the valence on your data set the more
connections there are within your data
that's as simple as i could put it if
you have a better one select me
so keeping that in mind knowing
hopefully understanding what valence
means
over time the data that we collect
especially if we
are a data heavy company they can it can
become very very dense
we collect a lot of data over time and
it can become
very very complex and when we continue
to aggregate all this data and
run all of these analytics on it it can
become
way more unevenly connected meaning
the relationships between them can kind
of be like
five percent connected but then this one
could be 25 percent connected
and then maybe some data from five years
ago
is somehow connected to data you're
going to collect in the future
these kinds of connections these kinds
of relationships they become
much much harder to analyze and moreover
break down
especially if you are using analytics
tools that
for the most part have been built on top
of the relational data model so
for scenarios like this new sql
databases
may probably come to the rescue for you
specifically graph databases
because they are way more expressive in
in showing you the connections and
relationships of your data
especially if they are this complex and
this irregular
so is nosql the way to go
again if you are on that top spectrum
there if you have
large data volume if you have a high
velocity of data meaning that
the you have a lot of rights the data
points in that you're storing changes
often
as well as your schema your data model
changes often maybe you're adding fields
left and right taking them
out if if that's high if you have
a wide variety of data of volatility
a high volatility of data meaning your
data is all over the place it's varied
it's not as
uniform as you would expect it to be and
if your data valence
is high meaning you have a lot of
connections that may not
be as easily modeled in a relational
database
then yes yes nosql is
probably the way to go it's a general
rough rule there are of course
exceptions but in in essence
yes you can be confident that that is
the way to go
however if you're on the opposite side
if your volume is not that large if
you're not
you know having to deal with web scale
if if your
velocity of data is pretty consistent or
predictable
you don't need to you know that it's not
going to change
often if the data that you have is more
uniform it's more homogeneous it's
you know what kind of data you're going
to be getting and if the connections
that you have
can be expressed uh just fine with the
relational databases
then sorry to say but it's probably not
the way to go
you probably are going to be better off
just sticking with a relational database
so yes the title of my talk may have
been like
i work for mongodb and i'm going to sell
you nosql but that's not the case i want
to just show you
at least a framework a guideline some
steps
that you can hopefully take with
yourself and your team when you're
brainstorming
to kind of get these kinds of questions
answered to see if it's really right
for you
so great now we know is nosql the way to
go
based on these four characteristics so
step one
check let's say that we find ourselves
on the
higher end of those characteristics so
we move on to the next step
and i like to call that acid or base
and again i want to make very clear
these are not one-to-one comparisons
i like to think of them as the the set
of properties that i think the system
requires and so when we're thinking
about these
the questions that i think are the most
important when deciding among these
these two models is
these four values here
so if you know that you need safe rights
if you know that those need to be
prioritized over fast rights
if you know you have money to spend on
high-end hardware or know that you're
going to be scaling vertically
and if you know that you need a
pessimistic model a rigid model
because of the right safety that you
need
then okay fine we'll go with relational
databases because again the fact of the
matter is
it's probably going to be the best bet
for you
they're uh they have been built with
these properties in mind
and they have just been working that way
for a while
so if these are the kinds of guarantees
that you require in your system
then yes we're going to go to relational
databases
it is worth noting though just a little
side note that there are some nosql
um databases that do offer asset
guarantees to an extent
so for example neo4j the graph database
does offer acid compliance in their
graph databases
same with mongodb at least via version
4.0 and higher
we do have multi-document acid
guarantees
now if you're thinking okay well the
system doesn't need to be that rigid
what we're building here
doesn't really need that what we need to
focus on is
fast rights we need to prioritize how
much we can write and how much we can
get stored in our database the safety of
it is not as important it doesn't mean
we're going to neglect it
it doesn't mean we're not going to have
it at all it just means it's not a
priority
and if we know that this model that we
require
can be more optimistic if we know that
it can be more
loose than the more rigid acid
properties that we have seen
then base is probably the um
set of guidelines that you want to look
for when you are choosing
whether or not to go with a nosql
technology or
no sql database and for that reason
because
most new sql databases do fulfill
these properties these base properties
then
that's another reason to say yes you
have passed
step two uh you fall within those those
lines and you can
probably move ahead and keep going
towards
some kind of nosql tech
so we have gotten through nosql
databases we know that if we have high
data volume if you have high data
variety our valence
is high and we have a high velocity of
data
that has checked we get to the next
point if we know that the
models that we need the properties that
we need
fall more in line with the base
properties they're a little bit more
loose a little bit more optimistic we
can finally now get to the third step
which is where i think a lot of us tend
to start
and that is the cap filter so
this is where i think a lot of us start
we just go what are we using
and we don't really think of anything
else and i think that's completely
turned uh turned around we shouldn't
start with the tech
we shouldn't say oh we're going to use
that immediately because i read some
tweets somewhere that it's amazing
and it's going to be great uh i i don't
think we should start that way
i think that if we have gone through the
first two steps of
asking ourselves of really truly
understanding what our system
requires by the time you get to this
step it's almost
then it should almost be very very quick
because
if you know that you need a partition
tolerant consistent
consistent system for example then you
can start to narrow
down the available systems that fulfill
that
and then once you have that you can
narrow down even further via
the data model that you find will be the
most useful for you
so for example if we have gotten to this
point it's almost like a
a funnel or a sieve that has said okay
not move this out of the way move this
out of the way and we're now
excuse me at step three and we are
we have answered all those questions we
know that we need
at the very end a partition tolerant
consistent system
now the only thing you'll have to do is
decide what data model to use
so you know if you know you need a
document database hey mongodb
i think it's a great choice and maybe a
little bit biased but
that's something that is i think a
little bit easier to go through versus
starting with mongodb then researching
everything else and then finding out oh
this doesn't have something that we need
or some other characteristic or let's
say you needed some kind of a key value
store then you would go to redis
and same thing with the other different
data models
at this point it should be much easier
for you to decide
which one to go with because you'll have
your little
checklist of things that you know you
need from the previous two steps
and you'll know that you can kind of
have a framework and check against those
things when you are
eventually researching the um tech that
you need
now on the other hand if you need a
partition tolerant available system and
you know you need a wide column store
cassandra's your best bet or you could
start looking at couch couchdb
at amazon dynamodb react again it's the
same
thing where if you know you've gotten to
this point the last thing to do
is see which data model fits for you and
then find the database that
matches that so
at the end of this three-step guide
um what i have hopefully shown here is
that
it's not necessarily a foolproof way to
say
this is the right tech that we're going
to use
not at all this is more of a framework
almost an exercise for your team to be
able to say
do we know the answers to these
questions do we know what we truly need
and do we know that we're not going to
be biased or swayed any one
way because of superfluous reasons
if we can answer the questions in uh
step one which is
is our data volume high velocity high
valence high variety high then you can
be a little bit more confident that
whatever whatever nosql database you end
up choosing
it's going to work for you same thing
you kind of just filter it down even
further if you go through the acid and
base
exercise and see which properties that
you need
again you're just more solid and you're
more confident in your decision
because you are aware of the properties
that your system will need
and finally by the time you get to the
cap filter which should remain at step
three i
wholeheartedly believe it should be much
easier to just focus then on the data
model
that you need
so with all of that said i hopefully
i'm not necessarily hoping i've changed
your mind specifically and said yes
nosql databases
but i'm hoping that this has shown you a
way
a smarter way to consider if nosql
databases is right for you and
in the end naturally you'll say yes
and that is say yes to nosql databases
so that is it for me thank you salamat
that is thank you in tagalog um and that
is it for me i'll be select
checking out the slack if you have any
questions i will post the
link to my slides there thank you for
your time and i hope you enjoy the rest
of the last day of nbc sydney
you